hey forgot to mention something super duper
important for you Marvel fans the three of
us are going to be having a Comic-Con panel
that's right a real rejects panel at this
year's Comic-Con Marvel might not be there they
got too intimidated once they heard that we were
showing up more details of date and time of when
it's all going to go down what's going on there
citizens of the reject Nation we are here to watch
episode dose of secret Envision Jean how are you
terrible yes and koi do better uh all right
yeah you are French ladies and gentlemen you
know what to do invade that like button do it
and also subscribe click that notification Bell
get notified when our next reaction for secret
evasion is up here on the Chanel and as always
if you want to sync up with us full-length
Reaction watch launchers with your own copy of
secret evasion available for super sexy Rejects at
our patreon page thank you to all who have joined
our patreon cover a bunch of stuff exclusively
over there as well let's swing no action people
still in the 90s where's that needle
drop welcome I'd like you to meet someone
this is graphic you son of a [__] kill
him piloted a ship all on his own he is
smart Fury knows how to survive we could use
someone like him hire further faster baby
if I don't deliver on my promise
create an alliance against me
this work here you know it's very dangerous
I'm not afraid I can see you're not
good talk for those of you who braved the journey
here to Earth you did so for one reason this man
oh Nicholas the world
is facing a serious threat and I could use your
help putting on a new face and keeping it this
is the promise not about it while you work
to keep my home safe we'll find you a new one
what a fascinating ask you keep your word I'll
keep mine I'm gonna think about that for a second
homeboy feels hurt
oh
woof not even Nick could tell
I was him he's losing his Edge
foreign
they've gone
the new Marvel cap yeah
the one time she said I mean something
I don't know about you and Susie
me and Susie had a standing game of doctor oh man
Susie saw a bullfrog with polka dots my mama just
told her everything she needed to know it's an
allegory oh you want to go for your rounds sure
tell me something I don't know
about the destruction of Scrolls
you know everything I believe you they're here
there's a million Scrolls walking amongst us
right now and every scroll that isn't in Emperor
George's colony hi to me hmm I could let my people
be annihilated or summon them here to Earth
what would you have done this ain't about me
all right but you find using us as your spies and
your air in boys as long as it's on your terms
here it is because you were gone and
you know what even when you did come
back there was no talking to you about
anything real your boots barely hit Earth
My Hope Is that with your help this
Crossing humans can co-exist here on
Earth can't coexist what are you trying to say
love we've been at war with each other since we
could walk upright there's not enough room or
Tolerance on this planet for another species
I think this is just a what don't you need
him to cover for you it's nice that they have
two Powerhouse actors and they're letting them
demonstrate that power yeah absolutely they're
both incredible cinemarvel I'm so glad this is
a show not a movie we would not get those kind
of movies the movies are the worst no but we get
six hours instead of like two how did it happen
quickly don't you be one of those bastards who
gives me a platitude when
I'm looking for the truth
she died in Moscow we were there trying to
stop the attack someone said a trap Mama Hill
someone wanted to hurt me so they
heard her damn the weight I don't know
what Maria died for out there but whatever
it was don't let it be for nothing fix this
[__] Fury I really love that we get to
see this side of Nick Fury while the NATO
Secretary General says NATO is acting swiftly to
gather Intel on the bomb scroll that's for what
the Kremlin regards as an all-out declaration
of war by the Americans they're all saying we
there's no way that Moscow attack was committed by
Americans this has got false flag written all over
it he's gonna come back Shooter McGavin always
comes back how did you know Fury would be there
it didn't but I hoped I wanted to see how much
of him was left you know I could have killed him
if I wanted to damn he's taking Delight
in this just get me to the council meet
I want to see their faces while moscow's still
burning I wonder how much of this mission is
imbued in Revenge I like the client confidence
of this guy this actor he's got such a baby face
I think it works for him because like there's
so much malice and then you've got like this
cherubickness yeah there's duplicitousness
about it the duality of his face really
I don't know
shoot him in the head all dressed up in
the man's finery drinking the man's wine
playing the minds game using the man's Falcon
knife better to behave as a human than as a
dog they're all Scrolls what the hell gives you
the right to disobey this counsel Michigan yet
I like how so much of the show is
about consequences and reaction
and failures of the heroes we followed
yeah it's really cool I think it's a war
and what happens if the Avengers return
put your facing me I promise Avengers really are
gone huh yeah they're all over the place now we
need a single Commander whose war power is total
and unchecked my God therefore I nominate graphic
yep I'm the commander of NATO I can
mobilize a million troops at this level
whoa all it takes is one now I know what to
do in live streams when John doesn't shut up
in our history we ended up homeless
refugees because we were too willing
I will not support your War I am
ready to die you're gonna be sister
you'll not be harmed respect
I don't agree with this it's not like the humans
have been opposing or segregating the Scrolls
and most of them don't even know you're here yeah
and we've seen some crazy [__] lately
let's try us Green Scene than purple scene
and a blue scene and a red scene posing
colors duality he has control of our
people and our future we're gonna have this
conversation with that guy right there yeah
that's nice graphic has changed someone's
dead but if you can't keep it together
you will not walk out alive surely
keep it together gravel on his voice
Harvest wasn't there
graphic has given me multiple locations
for the Harvest all of them empty
like someone's having trouble keeping promises too
what is that what are they building
I hope it leads to a big CGI battle
kind of Rhodes Terence Howard next time I can't
take the authenticity of Russian supplied photos
at face value however I will be more than happy
to have them analyzed at our facilities at Langley
saying about our photos how do you explain Mr
Fury's presence in Moscow alleged presence Madam
Slovakia rolls the size of me one more time
I'm gonna put on the suit and carpet bombing
careful surely president ritzen is aware of
the seriousness until such time as you can
present an actual shred of evidence to back those
concerns up I'm afraid sensitivity is all you're
going to be getting from us well handled Brody
I would just always use I helped defeat Thanos
I saved all of you so shut up I assume Armani
it's pretty expensive for a government salary
yeah well my other suits made of titanium so
this actually constitutes considerable savings
Croatia talking crap Slovakia or
carpet bomb there it is one o'clock
do me a favor and try not to pop off a
nuclear Holocaust before you get there
one of the post-credits scene of the season
is just him carpet bombing Slovakia faces all
over CCTV footage I was there trying to stop
the attack meaning you not only set the stage
for World War III but you simultaneously flipped
all of our allies to Team Russia nice one Fury
how well do you know your security detail
what if I told you they were all spies Hydra
yeah if Hydra was a bunch of green guys who could
shape-shift into your daddy just say Scrolls man
I don't think he knows that Don knows
or Brody knows so how long have you
known about them eyes only top secret
presentation the Pentagon was concerned
that they might get into their heads
to invade us one day from the inside
oh is real that's not possible that's what
I thought too but it's true it's a secret
maybe we should call our friends we get them in
a fight with the Scrolls and next thing you know
they find themselves duplicated and turned into
terrorists Fury this is my War we're 80 are there
okay I'm not doing it are you really talking to
me about politics right now I'm here as an Envoy
of the United States government Fury the job is
political I remember when your job was protecting
the planet it's like Civil War stuff right here
we owe each other so let's make the power mean
something Apple growth out cars outside colonel
this conversation's gone far enough Colonel these
men are going to escort you outside then you're
going to the airport have you even listened to a
word that I've said the enemy is a million times
more dangerous than Hydra but they can only be
vanquished by you but you should know better than
most it's just so well written it really is the
point of this power is to be uncompromising to be
able to sit across from a man we greatly admire
and to tell him without any reservation that he's
fired whoa whoa oh my God I want your gun in your
badge on my desk dick Fury Rogue Nation yes is
it you to fire me I volunteer that mess that you
created in Moscow that resulted in getting one of
our best people murdered you earned all this smoke
brother brother wow woof I can't wait for the
armor War show and I'm so excited can't wait to
watch Roadie debate people just because you
shook me in my titles I relinquished my DNA
whoa ouch and you wonder why you're out
I'm Nick Fury even when I'm out I'm in
a great lover s
daddy Fury that was such a
well-written scene this show
is so well written I'm so impressed
it's like the Andor of the MCU yeah
yes and now that the door is unlocked
what does that tell you about me and doors
imagine if this came out after end game and like
this is such a good sequel to where we left things
if your mother ever warn you could lose
an eye by beating your meat like that
where is the escape hatch in this dump why
do you need to know that oh just a hunch
well now that's confirmed oh my that's where she
started the interrogation I was not I did not
think they would share something like that yeah
it was a high crop dude good implication oh my God
foreign
I thought to myself what kind of
coward sends his daughter to do
what he wouldn't but you know then I
realized that kind of cow would just
doesn't have it in him well you don't know
that coward I'll never talk to you that's
very brave but everyone talks when their blood
starts to cook at 160 degrees Centigrade the
smart one start talking earlier than that
I you're a smart one are you a smart one
wow that works fast
not kill them I think it does but they get stuff
first maybe what's he gonna become tell me the
location of Graphics compound we swear I don't
know nothing please grab a game something a secret
and what Secrets doesn't he keep
Tell Me Something I Don't Know
he's building a machine what kind of
machine I think it's to make us stronger
super perhaps who's leading the science
it's a married couple what's their name
please read Richard sorry but if I didn't get a
name I won't get the chance to kill you oh boy
this does look painful the name's dolphin oh
you see that wasn't so terribly difficult was it
I know the sausage is gonna explode
oh nice good timing yes this is Matt
but also damn it that's a really
effective silencer damn it is so
silent you can't even hear the glass
break it silences everything silence
thank you
sounds like your lift is here escape hatch
nice good throw
oh [__] oh leather faced them it's like
actual blood effects cool Dostoyevsky
laughs
well done I got him let's go
nothing just lies just lies
that's all I swear look at him and say that
yeah you looked at the floor keep driving
let's define our safe house
oh
let me make it home pain
almost there bro
come here I want to show you something
oh that shot getting to you
listen to your conscience
I really like how the scrolls are just portrayed
like people people trying to get by like they need
guns and everything you know they're also that
he's the one that is allowed like allowed to
have a gun they're always giving it back to
him like he's that leader yeah dictator wow
oh interesting was I right I
think your vitamins was I right
he was shacked up with a scroll
Fury good for Nick Nick scrolly
aren't you forgetting something
all right run back out to the store
hahaha who have you been out seeing
almost
that's what I'm talking about that's
right let's get some romance go wood
Fade to the bedroom
damn what Colby Smulders appearing in a box
yeah I was like I don't think they even showed
her physically nah but they mentioned her
they mentioned her name man that was good
that was great man that was scrolltastic quality
I wish there are like 10 episodes of the show how
many episodes are going to be because it's great
it's just these two shows over Nick Fury goes home
to his wife who's done yeah as I got fired oh man
I kept thinking in this episode that uh if this
would had come out like like year after end game
and if we had like less stuff in between like what
a different conversation there would be because
this feels like such a cool sequel to The paranoia
of the dusting to like trauma there's so much
remorse it's just so good yeah it's really well
done really well done Jonathan oh man I cannot
agree more I'm very intrigued like the second
this the second I got the sense you know that the
episode was ending I was like ah damn like both
of these had that quality of like I don't want
to stop watching and I love that I mean there
has been physical Stakes there has been action
there have been deaths and things but so much
of it is just debate which is uh great especially
when something like this can compel with that I'm
really impressed that the action choreography is
as good as it is alongside how good the dialogue
is I feel like a lot of times with shows you
kind of have to choose like the directing either
um uh lends itself to good conversation action or
the directing lens itself to good action but the
the style of the cinematography doesn't feel
too disparate when it changes from an action
scene to a a dialogue scene but it allows for
both to feel authentic because it doesn't have
that green grass quality where it's like I
don't know what's happening and I love green
grass because that works for that world but it
wouldn't work here whereas this is like a nice
whole to the choreography has to be so tight
that it looks plausible well yeah and the way
they shoot this stuff is like it has a nice visual
style but it's not overly flashy either yeah you
know well I think with the action too they wanted
to be reflective of who the characters are what's
our main what's our main guy's name again uh
graphic graphic yeah with graphic uh even with
him just showing how John Wick tactile he is
demonstrates doesn't waste time how big of a
position he like not only is he the strategist
and the great great manipulator he is also
um The Ultimate Warrior of them all you can see
how much he has trained himself to become who
he is and you see that's really demonstrating so
not only is he a mental threat that you have to
go up against but he's also a physical threat
that you have to compete with at the same time
and I love the layers that they have shown with
him because he he he's the one who's inspiring
the people the scrollopolis I like to call it
he's the one inspiring them yet you get these
shades of conniving Menace and villainy you know
piercing through these little smirks that he has
so it's like I I I I haven't really gotten
a full sense of what like he just seems like
he wants domination like he just wants to run
whatever it is there is no there is no remorse
as they point out for this character like there
were 2 000 people who were killed and it is an
interesting conversation they're having because
you know they're factoring in the history of what
brought the Scrolls here to Earth and they're
kind of forgetting a lot of what initially got
them there in the first place and this invasion is
not something where you know they're retaliating
because of how they've been treated right you know
like most people don't even know about them yeah
they they are just kind of dominating and it is
it is really cool where it's so different from
the comic in every way because like the Scrolls
the comics are like loud just like big letters
yeah we're aliens yeah we're aliens we've come to
destroy you people you know um but I love just the
humanistic portrayal that they're they're giving
here uh it's it's very interesting it really suits
this medium and I I always talk about what like
adaptation versus translation is for Comics to
shows this is such a better take for this medium
I think when you have an event comic you need a
bad guy so in the comic books you need like green
aliens that are yelling about alien stuff but in
a show that wouldn't work and in a show that's
this well written you can really make it about
violence and refugees and history and it really
is a great commentary and so many of our things
by looking at our problems from an outside lens
and I loved like the the subverting expectations
of like having graphic let her go when she decided
not to join the coup I thought that was genius too
show mercilessness towards violence uh failing
and show seeming Mercy towards like I understand
where you're coming from and that makes it much
more interesting than the choice of like okay
she dies and and then the rest of the time you've
got this fear and intimidation and he really seems
like he's wanting to help his people because of
that letting her go as opposed to him just being
a malevolent dictator because he mostly is yeah
I love what they're doing with the whole scroll
Community yeah and it's interesting too that
with Nick Fury uh and a lot of the conversation
was even brought up as well with Roadie how they
are factoring I feel like this is the first time
with Nick fear that they're actually exploring
the fact that he's black you know and going in
through a lot of the history and the struggles
and the impression as well of wanting to belong
as well and wanting to be accepted yeah and
they're they're using that lineage in a way that
is semi-reflective of what's going on with the
Scrolls as well which I thought they did a good
job with Miss Marvel with when they when they tied
in like Muslim culture and Muslim Heritage with
where we're leading with mutants where they made
it a commentary on feeling othered being outside
and then like this is doing it with historically
American treatment of things and I like the the
those two paths being like guys look at what we've
done there are ramifications but not being I mean
there's people going to complain but but not being
in a way that feels like it's the only purpose of
it like it feels like it serves the story not uh
it has to be the story yeah and also like with
Nick Fury and Rhody in that conversation when that
topic was brought up of that doesn't mean that we
should just give each other a pass just because
we have difference of beliefs that we have to
you know just agree to these things because like
Roadie's stance is so like drastically different
on this matter yeah um that was a great again I'm
a big fan of like when you write a really strong
debate and I think this this show I mean they
had two great scenes here uh two great Powerhouse
scenes with Nick Fury where him and Talos at the
very beginning on the on the train yeah feeling
like they're being light like you know being lied
to and also were tell us tell us or Talos it's a
falcon or Falcon um in the show they seem to be
going with Talos in the movie I thought it was
Talos but well Nick Fury says Talos so I suppose I
should alter my pronunciations yes Carlos actually
Carlos but yeah we're talos's anger was coming
out as well like I think these act they got so
many is it Olivia Coleman an oscar-winning
actress too then she went I think so in the
last five years I think she won an Oscar as well
yeah I don't think Ben Mendelson's won but he's
not he should yeah he's one of the best um but to
have just these actors here and they and like Don
Cheadle too who is also an Oscar nominated
too this was like man we're really finally
those Roadies usually just like he's cool right
and I'm always like you guys have donkey yeah
and that's my biggest issue with the MCU of
of like the the 15-year run and sometimes they
cast so well that I'm like it's not cheating yeah
like can you can you let donji utilize what their
range is truly capable of and what everything
Brewing underneath the surface we want to see
that come out and I think they capture that
with Nick Fury and Taylor's on the train and
that's why you do the show yeah like this is
what I feel like you could have gotten these
scenes in a movie too no I don't think like
look we've already spent two hours they'd be
over like this is what happened at the one hour
mark no but this is episode two I know but it
happened at the one hour market for factoring
in the runtime of when those scenes occurred
sure but I don't want that to be the whole thing
like this would be the end of the movie we'd be
done and I think that the reason you do television
is because Comics are serialized so you can have
a slow burn build up and I think that that when
when they announce the Marvel Cinematic Universe
shows tying into the movies and saying this is
gonna be one big universe I thought it was for
stuff like this like this is what you can build
and I think this you need these actors to get
more time to play this is why donofrio is one of
the best villains because you let Kingpin be as
captivating as Daredevil now we've got an entire
Invasion that's just as interesting as the Thanos
subplot that took 10 movies to build to like
this is why you do TV yeah I completely agree
and the budget allows for you to sit in a room
and talk and also the uh it forces you too also
um and and also how it's dealing so much with the
ramifications of Nick Fury's choices yes of not
helping out and you could tell there's that guilt
like he does feel solely responsible for it and I
even thought the justification of not calling in
The Avengers was like that is so smart yeah what
are you gonna do the face normally uh like I think
in the trailers or something they were like nah
this is this is what something I gotta do it's my
personal mission yeah but when you're seeing the
trailers with like a bunch of action and [__]
you're like I don't know man calling the Avengers
like you're putting more people in danger by
just doing this yourself kind of selfish yeah
um but the conversation that he had with uh
Roadie there I was like damn that is so well
Justified of why not to call it the event one of
the best in comic book mediums to not have like
everything always be an Avengers level event it's
always so frustrating when you've introduced these
characters like you've got their phone number
like and then this one did that but in a way
that feels like it serves not only the medium but
also uh the the tone but you can tell how it could
build to an Avengers level 100 if not um uprooted
properly or perhaps a Fantastic Four Level Threats
perhaps some super skrills are introduced in
this maybe they're building Fantastic Four
could have like it actually feels like that that
when they introduced that orb it feels like maybe
that's them building a super scroll thing well
yeah what they they show like when they're going
through the extremist and the Groot that there's
gonna be scroll through upgrade that's what I
think is really cool about this is because right
now what we're seeing as Scrolls when they're
just humanistic they you know they need guns they
need all these other things but they don't have
superpowers rather than shape-shifting yeah and
then and then eventually they're going to evolve
the evolution of mutation with scientific level
so it's not like uh natural mutation but they're
going to infuse it with stuff so that's what they
were setting up right that's what I gathered yeah
and I feel like this tone is is gonna make it so
when we have them in a movie that's only like you
know your 90 minute two hour We're invested in
the origin of how they got cool as opposed to
the comics or the cosmic rays maybe like it's just
like this is more exciting for me to make it more
plausible but like in this tone and genre yeah
that it's great stuff great stuff John you guys
grow on you yeah a little bit it's funny and she
didn't speak heartly at all but I actually kind of
liked just being able to observe her body language
and yeah she did feel uh you know more engaging to
me and sort of alive here as you watch her you
know flip back and forth between like oh maybe
graphic is going a little too hard at this but
also I'm still dedicated to the cause so uh so
yeah it's not a Gaia Rich episode necessarily but
I did uh find myself a little bit more interested
in her just you know Journey from here and and
two I really appreciated that they start the
episode in 95 and then you jump to 97 and you see
the warping you know 99. but maybe we'll see the
metrics but I like that you know it's like we're
you know 30 odd years on from that in the timeline
and and you know at the start of a movement like
this at the start of a refugee situation like this
the sentiments are different and then you can
see how they would warp change complacency can
set in for one group of a group within the group
and then you have characters like gravic who you
can see this has sort of festered over time to
the point where they you know he has developed
this extreme uh philosophy and I think that
that's just another you know nice way too to
complement the idea of yeah you have Roadie
and fury discussing generational things and
cultural things multiplied by gaps in generation
and you have a similar different but similar thing
happening with the Scrolls there too that also
applies to a character like Gaia and I like that
the time works because Samuel Jackson in real life
has dealt with all that like the Samuel Jackson's
real story is staggering and like when he was a
child like all the things that he was involved
with in his lineage his parents and it's cool
to have an actor that it really puts timelines
in perspective like how recently things were
even more [__] in our world and so to have
the Scrolls go back to the 90s you know that's
30 years ago now so we're gonna have multiple
generations of them feeling oppressed we're gonna
have multiple generations of like them growing
up so it's more Justified that they're gonna have
this war they're trying to cook up so I like tying
in you know Samuel Jackson who's lived through so
much his story feels so authentic and then like
these I'm glad the Scrolls were set in the 90s is
what I'm saying I'm glad Captain Marvel was set
long enough ago that there's like this Slow Burn
percolation like this thing that's boiling under
the surface it's not like hey they landed they're
mad they're aliens it's like no no we've not done
the thing we promised they've been in hiding and
and like the kids of them are never going to know
Freedom like that our our villain was a child who
who came to this angry he set all that time to
train to become angry to become this leader become
this thing and he's justified in his feeling
oppressed I think it's really beautiful parallel
storytelling he almost said percolating German s
but you know what's also cool is uh it's not
Duality I was gonna try and segue that way but
him him talking to Telus and telling the story
about tell me what is something I don't know that
reminded me that pulled me all the way back to
what is that Civil War when he's telling the story
about his I can't remember now it's like his dad
or somebody or somebody he used to know who would
like walk this bag of he would like deliver a bag
every night and then you know the the story grow
I'm not going to paraphrase it well here but he
that was your dad's story that was my that's your
life I wish Nick Fury was my dad and I think maybe
Age of Ultron I do know what you're talking about
um and like that he tells that he relates a
personal story that does go on as like a monologue
that then and factors into the overall point in
a way that does feel it was one of those things
where I'm like oh yeah he is like a person with
experience yeah that's just a cool guy well what
stood out to me in the opening credits was when it
said executive produced by Sam Jackson sure and I
did not know that I didn't either I wish I had
and I feel like he really got involved I agree
actually making sure this character felt more
human and fleshed out uh because this is easily
shaping up to be the best Nick Fury portrayal so
far from Samuel Jackson um because you get so many
it doesn't feel like they're doing a rewrite on
the character it just feels like you're getting
a better understanding of the character you know
what I mean like you're seeing like these softer
sides to him these more compassionate sides and
in some ways like that the more the more Humanity
angles of him seem to have come through with
the relationships that he formed with the scroll
and boy we're even married one you know uh I think
that's awesome because he's usually around humans
he even talks about like humans can't even get
along you know yeah you you see how with that
with whatever he's interacting with humans it
just seems so like freaking tough and on edge
is a hard ass but the softer side comes out of him
which was set up in Captain Marvel but now you're
seeing it in the show even more so that there is
some there is that softer human to this guy yeah
and now we get to really see that in a way that
doesn't feel like it's undoing the Nick Fury that
we know totally agree sometimes when you change
a character that much it's like wait are they
playing the same character this feels very natural
so we write them for television or like it's got
to fit this narrative huh yeah it's not that I I
think they've done a great job with a lot of these
things that I felt like Falcon and Winter Soldier
were trying to do but they're making it more
interesting and better action all the time well
and they don't seem like they're shying away from
things that overlap with real world conflicts the
Wake Falcon Winter Soldier like literally removed
aspects like that and and even like there's
elements to the Scrolls that remind me of the flag
Smashers but this is better done um this is a lot
of things I wanted that show to land yeah so far
also Alfred Woodard uh I as Charlene Woodard like
related I have no idea Priscilla I assume it's
his wife uh I don't know if we got her name but
the scroll guard played by Luke J Smith related
to Will Smith I mean they must be no but like
a woodard's not not as common as Smith and she
also like has a presence too I'm just wondering
if Alfred Woodard has like a sibling uh John
um I loved Olivia Coleman's um the violence that
comes out within her I love what do you think
about Olivia Coleman she was terrific I she it's I
think it's an easily it's easy to fall into being
the Trope of being yeah like ooh Charming bubbly
but also ruthless but I think she just she is such
a good actress that she makes me believe that even
though I'm waiting to see you know for we've only
had a couple scenes with her and so far it's all
you know what she shows to the outside I'm curious
to see what's underneath but I think she's killing
it right now and her scenes are a really nice
change of tone because it brings all that Menace
but she's just a fun and and quirky to watch
um and I love that they have her Talent here
as well and I can't wait to see just her role
increase in all of this because she's clearly
very capable I loved how we've set up gravic and
I'm trying to find her name
Sonia Sarah kravik and Sonia
um but you only see them from the political side
first and then this episode towards the end you
get to see what they're like in the field when
they're getting their hands dirty yeah yeah it's
really neat they've done a lot of really cool
stuff with this I'm really impressed with this
this is like the kind of drama I would put on
and watch at home by myself I'm not gonna lie
I'm not gonna lie at one point I was so in
the show I was like do I want to just watch
this like not work like and I don't usually feel
that way I'm like I'm like do I want to just like
not be doing it this way but like I really like
sharing an art but this Show's so good I'm like
I feel like it's for me yeah I love that like
this is all the things I liked about Loki where
it's the two-person conversations that I loved
in Loki but with an even more sizable ensemble
cast of Powerhouse so that can all do that kind
of work that Owen Wilson and Tom Hiddleston did
yeah so I mean if this sticks The Landing it's
definitely on the top three hope to God it sticks
The Landings right now it's really setting itself
apart it feels so different in all the right ways
and I'm just getting worried that they're
gonna pull that Disney plus finale episodes
we were so close to it yeah dropping the
ball if it does though man yeah this is
this is top tier Marvel because the
pacing is on point and the writing is
really strong and the acting is so
good that I'm like I don't want to
over compliment you just yet because
I've been down this road before yeah
uh but really maybe that's Marvel
this it it could like it feels like
real uh High reference feels like a real movie
It's a drama like they've they've really
committed to it being a drama and it
doesn't feel like they're trying to do any
audience satisfaction [__] it definitely
feels like a Prestige Showtime or HBO drama
it feels like a Prestige show that happens to
somehow have green aliens in it like it's
so good it's like the Americans you know
like the show is the Russians yeah oh yeah
yeah um is that Kerry Russell Clara Danes
I'm totally forgetting is on homeland
home oh no yeah but also you know yeah
yeah yeah um yeah guys what'd you think
about this episode leave your thoughts
down below uh be sure to subscribe and leave
a like and uh follow us on patreon and we'll
Adelia Chamberlain Adelia if there's anyone
who's a scroll at our patreon page it's a hundred
percent you I see what's happened in this world of
YouTube I see you now working for a bunch of these
different people all the time it's an invasion
it's an invasion that's what you've done you've
come in here pretending under the guys that you're
just a fan no no no you don't have this sheepish
shy timid woman you're far from that that was
all a con all and act a Comic Con you might
say it was all no so that way you could weasel
your way in and then boom get this new career
working with the top dogs and the big leagues and
what I say to you Bravo well done respect they
don't hate the player hey the game and man
I love the player here oh yeah you play us
awesome you know how to do it it's a new form of
female seduction is what you've pulled off here
and I find it very impressive Adelia gosh we need
more Scrolls like you in this world who know how
to insidiously invade their way in because you
don't want to be obvious about it you knew how
to do it in a way where no one would ever suspect
and I could learn a thing or a lot of people could
learn a thing or two from you oh yeah and you
earned all of it because you're actually good
at what you do yeah whatever A lot of people are
good at stuff proficient no but do quality work
being that awesome scroll uh-huh love you dear